I want to tell you about a very famous
number that you've heard about before
but I'll tell you why it is what it is
and it's the golden ratio a lot of
people think the golden ratio is this
mystical thing it is but not for the
reasons they think but I want to do that
and I tell you why it's interesting when
I do that through a mechanism of flowers
and you may have heard a connection with
the coordination flowers before but I'll
show you why that connection is there
for the sake of this nobody I'll I'll be
the scribe but I'd like you to imagine
Brady that you are a flower your job as
a flower is to deal with your seeds it's
kind of the job of everything living
you're gonna grow some seeds and we're
gonna model this flower in a
mathematical way
this is not how flowers actually grow
but there are connections this is the
center when you grow a seed I'm gonna
represent that by putting a little blob
that's a seed that you've going from the
center of your flower and one option you
could have is is you've got it so where
to put your seeds and I'm gonna give you
the option of only how much do you turn
around before you grow your next seed so
you put a seed down and you could turn a
bit and put another seat down kind of
growing it if you don't turn at all
you're gonna grow seeds out like this
the first he goes there if you don't
turn the next he goes next to it then if
one goes next to it you're gonna grow
the seeds out there and you're gonna
push seeds out actually I'm adding them
on the end but it grow from there and
push this seeds out on the line this is
a really bad arrangement for a flower I
hope you agree and I hope you weren't
imagining this when you were thinking of
a flower yeah there's a whole bunch of
circle unused so the obvious thing if
I'm gonna do this model of like if a
flower could just grow by putting a seed
in and turning a bit what would happen
if you turn an amount of a turn so I'm
gonna talk about fractions of turns this
is a fraction return of zero if you do
no one here with an you turn half a turn
each time then if the first seed goes
here then I think if you turn half turn
the next one's gonna go there if you
don't half turn again keep UN same
direction it's gonna go there and there
and this is also not exciting being kind
of see why the decision of turning a
half has made two lines and maybe gonna
call these spokes because just to get
you in the mood Lister third you could
probably predict it pretty easily see
turn that third of a turn or roughly
there third of a turn roughly there and
you're gonna see these three spokes
sticking out pretty easily happy enough
with this I mean these none of these are
good flower designs but the consequences
of choosing a number is giving you some
patterns so if I jump say to a tenth of
a turn would you care to predict what
you'd see yeah and so I don't think the
the spoke behavior is very surprising
and it looks like the denominator of
this
fraction of attorneys controlling
everything now I think it's much less
obvious if I told you what would happen
three tenths so with three tenths if you
start here you have three tenths of a
turn you'd skip a couple of the branches
and then that another three tenths you'd
skip a couple you get on here three
tenths you'd skip a couple go here and
if you keep going around you'll end up
not repeating yourself for a bit until
all ten are done
you also get tens books so there's this
really nice thing in mathematics called
a conjecture we pretty much have one
here looks like it's the denominator of
the fraction is controlling number
spokes so here's a quick computer model
of what we've been talking about and we
can check that with other tests before I
have 11 you may want to predict what
happens you're correct there 11 spokes
if you type in some other numbers there
are some surprises so I do 11 out of 23
you do get 23 spokes but there's some
interesting behavior happening in the
middle and that's actually it looks like
this kind of two spokes but they're kind
of twisted and that's because this
number is quite close to one over two
and it looks like what numbers you're
close to also affect what happens one
surprise that you should watch out for I
mean if I do seven tenths you know about
tenths you get ten of them but then
occasionally you catch yourself I you do
four tenths same thing are ten spokes
but there aren't is two-fifths and
flowers can cancel fractions or all I
can't actually and was it happening is
that four tenths is better described by
two fifths so you've seen lots of bad
flowers this is pretty but it's not what
flowers - what's interesting is if you
change this number very very slowly and
you realize that a tiny change gives you
very different behavior so this number
is changing ridiculously slowly but even
a small jump he's giving us spirally
shapes and very quickly they stop
looking like suppose that the number is
the fraction of a turn before I grow you
see so this number that's here is is
0.40 one of a turn when I go you see
them that's already enough to stop it
going in lines and they're starting to
bunch together and this is already
looking better a prettier thing for a
flower it's also nicely hypnotic if you
need to hypnotize people you start
seeing things kind of turning one way
but also maybe turning the other way you
see spokes arriving and disappearing and
this is already a better flower I'm
using it much more efficiently now I'm
not saying flowers are thinking about
this there's some how they do this
efficiently and we've got now an obvious
question is is there a fraction of a
turn that is an efficient one what's
really lovely about this is you can see
rational numbers arriving you can see
that I'm not out of fur
but already the number three is
dominating everything it's like hunting
for big game you can hear these animals
coming in the undergrowth you see it
this third is about to arrive or at
0.329 now and as soon as we hit exactly
a third we're gonna get those three
spokes and it's really nice to see it
arrive and then disappear so it's about
to get there as soon as we hit point two
three three three three two exactly as
long as the cows on forever you will see
our three spokes and then it's gone
we're in two other numbers if you put a
number in for a fraction of a turn and
it is a fraction ie hasn't denominated
it's gonna give you spokes and so maybe
we're into familiar territory from many
other discussions about numbers maybe
you could suggest a number greater you
could type in that wouldn't give me
spokes which is the square root of two
what do you think you're gonna see kind
of spirally spirals oh it looks less
like it's got spokes but you can't kind
of count them and it turns out that this
is definitely an irrational number I'm
approximating an irrational number on
computer but this arrangement looks much
better so it sounds like you've you've
hit upon the idea of maybe flowers need
to turn it irrational amount of a turn
but there are the irrational numbers I'm
gonna type in 1 over PI because PI's a
lot of people's favorite here of
rational number this surprised me think
about what you might see we know it
can't produce spokes because pi is
irrational now they're not quite spokes
but they're slightly curved spokes and
there are in fact 22 of them just to
save you counting I don't know if 22
rings of Bell to do with PI but if the
older generation needs to get toward
their pi was pretty much exactly the
ratio 22 over 7 it's not quite but it's
unreasonably good and you can see on
this diagram that is unreasonably good
because this is irrational but it's
really well approximated by something
through the number 22 in fact what I
love about this diagram is you can see
another approximation of Pi buried in
the middle there aren't 22 spokes in the
middle there are 3-3 is a very
well-known approximation for pi in fact
if I carried this diagram on really big
you see lots of rational approximations
for pi in the arrangements of seeds in a
flower or a mathematical flower but what
it also tells you is that pi is not very
irrational
it looks like root 2 is more irrational
so actually the obvious question which
is turned up in lots of situations and
maybe in other videos from me is that is
there one that's the most irrational and
there is and I'll show it to you and
then I'll show you why so here it is if
I jump to this square root of 5 minus 1
over 2 in this this is the golden ratio
of a turn and what's lovely about is you
can see spokes but you can see they're
going in both directions they're kind of
crossing over both ways and you could
try and count them and if you do you get
Fibonacci numbers and if you go and look
in the real world this is the bit a lot
of people claim is that this is what
sunflowers do so if I hide the seeds
there that's the arrangement of seeds in
the head of a sunflower
that's not generated by a computer this
is a flower doing something to be
efficient and if I put the seeds back
and hide it the the correlation between
those placements is is almost
frightening and what's lovely bad is
that no other number works so if I start
this animating again not the spokes are
obvious and this kind of unravels and
already you can see these spokes
unraveling and they're obvious spokes we
could count the spokes and figure out
what rational number was near so the
golden ratio looks like it's the best
one but I want to show you on paper why
is the best one and I'm gonna do that by
starting with pi because it's a good
place to start but pi is an irrational
number that apparently is not very
irrational and we kind of already know
that it's approximated well by a
rational number but let me show you how
you can sort of quantify that so I'm
gonna say that's high is three plus a
bit I don't think that's controversial
but what I'm interested in is writing
this number pi which I can never really
write down a full which is why we have
the symbol for it can I write it in a
way which looks more like a fraction
instead of like a decimal so 3 plus a
bit isn't very helpful but I could sage
since this bit is less than 1 otherwise
it could be 4 plus a bit right then I
could say this is 3 plus 1 over
something and I could find out what that
something is on a calculator I could
take away the 3 and I get into something
and then I could do 1 over there or X to
the minus 1 to find out what it is and
it actually is seven point something so
I'm gonna write this 1 over 7 plus a bit
the words a bit are not sort of
mathematically recognised terminology
but you get the idea so I could carry on
I know this 3 plus 1 over 7 plus a bit
and I could write that as 1 over
something and that's on my screen now so
I could take away the the 7 and get the
bit and do 1 over that and I get 15 and
a bit I can start writing 15 plus a bit
instead of doing me a bit now I'm just
gonna go straight in with 1 over
something take away 15 get the bit X to
the minus 1 do 1 over it and they get
one and a bit take away 1 through the
bits a very small bit this time and I
get to 9 2 and you can see that if this
number is truly irrational I could just
keep going and actually this thing here
is called the continued fraction for pi
and something very obvious happens with
the PI is that you get a very small
number here then you get a very large
number here in the trade they call it
truncating but if you chop the continued
fraction its own
you'll get an approximation so three and
a seventh is 22 over 7 it's a good
approximation for pi if you're talking
there you get a approximation if you
chop it there I'll chop it there but
because this number is massive
and it's one over that number this
additional bit is tiny well actually
after that goes back to being someone's
in the continued fraction but that
particular point it means that you don't
add very much accuracy at those two
levels truncation which means it was
really accurate before which means the
step before that was ridiculously good
which means pi is well approximated
quite early on by a rational number
which is why I'm gonna claim it's not
very irrational and why when you saw the
diagram of it looks like ants pokes so
looking in the continued fraction the
question is what would the most
irrational number look like it would be
the one with a continued fraction that
doesn't have any large numbers in it so
I'm gonna claim that this is a pretty
good candidate I'm gonna call it X so
the continued fraction would be let's
just start with one
but then the continued fraction would go
one over the smallest whole number one I
know have one here I don't have a one
here I have a one here and this is
something that a lot of people do
recognize it's an odd thing to ask what
it is but whatever it is it will be
badly approximated anytime you truncate
it because these numbers are small now
just as a little heads up I'm just gonna
tell you the root two has a continued
fraction as well one plus one over two
plus tonight with two two two and it
carries on like that which is
incidentally why root two looked pretty
good on our diagram because although
these are not the smallest numbers this
they're consistent and they stay small
what I want to get through with this
video you might know the answer but I
want to prove it is what is this number
I'm gonna solve this this is an infinite
thing but we can solve this surprisingly
easy because it carries on forever let
me point out something which i think is
obvious when someone points it out which
is that this thing is the same as the
whole thing it is X which means I can
sort of grab that thing and call it X I
can rewrite equation as x equals 1 plus
1 over X and that looks much less scary
in fact it's a quadratic equation which
I'm gonna solve I'm sure people watching
this video would have their favorite way
of solving quadratics I'm gonna do maybe
not quite the quadratic formula I've
seen a friend of mine called Matt Parker
try this with a quadratic formula
there's a better way I'm multiplying by
X to get x squared equals x plus 1 I'm
gonna rearrange it onto one side over x
squared minus X minus
one equals zero at this point a lot of
people reach for the quadratic formula
that minus B plus or minus the square
root I'm gonna complete this square
which is where the formula comes from so
I'm gonna realize that if I write X
minus 1/2 squared that would square to
give me an x squared it would also give
me the minus X I need try if you don't
believe it but it'll create a quarter
which I don't want from the 1/2 squared
and I still got a minus 1 here I'm just
gonna carry on putting this stuff on the
other side I get X minus 1/2 squared
equals combined in these I'm gonna get 5
over 4 and now I can square root it this
is the whole point of completing the
square X minus 1/2 equals plus or minus
the square root of 5 good at square root
of 5 over 2 because that's the square
root 4 and I'm gonna do one more step
and this needs a box because x equals
put this half on the other side that's
the same thing and this is equal to Phi
which is the golden ratio and it is the
most irrational number because of the
way it builds as a continued fraction
which is why it looks so nice when you
stack it around a sunflower and why it
carves a path through an infinite
orchard if anyone ever talked to you
about that that is farthest away from
all the other points and that's why Phi
is a cool number it's not because the
Greeks designed the Parthenon to look
like it because that was not true I
haven't done the job so which one is it
let me show you on a calculator if you
if you tap this in obviously this is
gonna give us an approximation but if I
do 1 plus the square root of 5 and
divide it by 2
I'll get a familiar number which is one
point four six one eight oh three 3 9
and so on now that is a familiar number
the golden ratio but if I did 1 minus it
and 1 minus the square root of 5 which
is the other option I had and divided by
2 I get negative zero point six one
eight four zero three three nine and
actually get the same decimal expansion
it just happens to be negative and this
is all because of the property of the
golden ratio that if you take away one
from it you get 1 over itself and that's
actually built into this equation and if
you make it negative you can get
reciprocals of itself so either of those
numbers are Leia claimed to be the
golden ratio and when I did it on the
sunflower
I actually used 0.618 0 339 because that
gave me a fraction between 0 and 1 but
they kind of all gone ratio or directly
we've evolved from it
[Music]
how about we check in on brilliance
problem of the week so the basic level a
vertex of one square is pegged to the
center of an identical square the
overlapping area is blue one of the
squares is then rotated about the vertex
and the resulting overlap is red which
area is greater what do you reckon fancy
edge answers over on intermediate or a
chess problem they're about promoting a
pawn or the advance problem if you're
feeling a little bit dangerous the
Centers of three identical coins form
the angle that's colored green what
angle maximizes the area of the blue
convex hull and you've got a whole range
of options you really have to check out
brilliant go to brilliant org slash
numberphile and check out their huge
range of courses and quizzes all sorts
of great stuff this is really gonna get
your brain working this is like kind of
going to the gym to make you smarter go
to brilliant org slash numberphile and
you can actually get 20% off a premium
membership go and check them out
brilliant org slash numberphile and our
thanks to them for supporting this
episode
you